so you got a year lease I put um the
down the down payment the security
deposit in the first month's rent well
that's already paid I got the cable
hooked up with the fast Wi-Fi the
electricity all set up and that'll be a
monthly bill and we have to talk about
when you guys are going to take over
um the payments
I wish I could get the job and then I
can because I can help you yeah but
whatever if you do this like for us like
taking someone
you know as soon as soon as you can but
um within the first two to three months
better for you better for us
oh my God
we've talked about this in Ethiopia and
now you know to work on a plan for your
own sustainability you know yeah of
course that's what we want to lead a
life that you want to lead
um
if I had to come here myself first I
definitely would have gotten a cheaper
apartment and not you know this is a big
stress on us right away getting the two
bedroom the expensive apartment in an
expensive place but the expensive cable
and everything and then telling us oh by
the way then you have to pay for all of
it so get a job really fast I mean we
have no idea what the future holds well
I'm so appreciative to my parents for
even finding the apartment and covering
the first month's rent I don't know if
it's realistic to expect us to be able
to start covering the rent on our own as
soon as possible it's good to start off
nice like this
I don't know what kind of job I'm going
to be able to get and he can't work for
at least 90 days until or more that he
until he gets his work permit so that's
another stressful thing
Finney and I only have a few thousand
dollars to last Us in the U.S the
immigration process is expensive and you
know we moved countries it's day one and
we already have to face this financial
stress okay good night I love you guys
tomorrow I'll be more appreciative when
I can open my eyes Vinnie and I had the
expectation that when we came to the U.S
everything will be different and new and
exciting and will be a chance to just
work on our relationships spend time
together as a family and start over
again okay log but I think neither of us
really know long term how we're going to
provide for the family it's really scary
like what if this doesn't work out
[Music]